bine ai revenit la Înțelegerea Informației și Computației Cuantice, numele meu este John Wattrus și sunt directorul tehnic
pentru educație la IBM Quantum. Aceasta este lecția a 11-a din serie și este a treia lecție din
a treia unitate, care tratează formularea generală a informației cuantice. Această lecție este despre măsurători, care reprezintă o
interfață între informația cuantică și cea clasică. Când se efectuează o măsurătoare asupra unui sistem aflat într-o
stare cuantică, se extrage informație clasică, dezvăluind ceva despre acea stare cuantică și modificând sau
distrugând de obicei acea stare în proces. Într-o formulare simplificată a informației cuantice, care a fost discutată
în prima unitate a seriei, ne restricționăm de obicei atenția la măsurători proiective, inclusiv
cel mai simplu tip de măsurătoare: măsurătorile în baza standard. Este însă posibil să generalizăm noțiunea de măsurătoare
și se dovedește a fi un lucru destul de util. În această lecție vom vorbi despre măsurători în toată generalitatea lor,
inclusiv despre cum sunt descrise în termeni matematici și cum se încadrează în formularea generală a
informației cuantice. Spre finalul lecției vom arunca și o privire asupra câtorva noțiuni fundamentale legate de măsurători, și anume discriminarea stărilor cuantice
și tomografia stărilor cuantice. Deci, să începem. Iată o prezentare generală a
lecției. Așa cum facem de obicei, vom începe cu elementele de bază, inclusiv câteva moduri diferite, dar echivalente, prin care putem
descrie măsurătorile în termeni matematici. În particular, putem descrie măsurătorile prin colecții de matrice
și le putem descrie și ca canale, lucru la care am făcut aluzie în lecția anterioară. Vom discuta și despre
măsurătorile parțiale, adică măsurătorile efectuate doar pe o parte a unui sistem compus mai mare.
Apoi vom trece la teorema lui Neymark, care este un fapt fundamental despre măsurători și care spune practic
că măsurătorile generale pot fi întotdeauna implementate într-un mod simplu, asemănător reprezentărilor Stinespring
ale canalelor. Pe scurt, măsurătorile generale pot fi întotdeauna implementate introducând mai întâi un
sistem workspace inițializat, apoi efectuând o operație unitară și în final efectuând o măsurătoare în baza standard
pe sistemul workspace. Acest lucru se dovedește a fi destul de ușor de demonstrat și vom vedea cum decurge, iar
vom vedea și cum se leagă de așa-numitele măsurători nedistructive, pe care le voi descrie în ultima parte a
lecției. Vom discuta despre discriminarea stărilor cuantice și tomografia stărilor cuantice. Vom începe cu descrierile matematice
ale măsurătorilor. Măsurătorile ne oferă o interfață între informația cuantică și
cea clasică. Când se efectuează o măsurătoare asupra unui sistem aflat într-o anumită stare cuantică, se extrage informație clasică
despre acea stare cuantică. În plus, starea cuantică este în general modificată sau posibil
complet distrusă. Inițial, ne vom concentra atenția asupra așa-numitelor măsurători distructive, unde
o stare cuantică intră și iese doar informație clasică, deci nu există nicio specificare a
stării cuantice post-măsurătoare a sistemului care a fost măsurat. Intuitiv vorbind, ne putem imagina că o măsurătoare distructivă
distruge orice sistem a fost măsurat, deci starea sa după ce măsurătoarea are loc nu este
specificată. Asta nu înseamnă literalmente că dispozitivele fizice sunt neapărat distruse, e doar o
descriere matematică și este una foarte utilă, deoarece ajută la simplificarea lucrurilor și la concentrarea pe aspectele matematice esențiale
ale măsurătorilor. Există în particular două moduri echivalente de a descrie măsurătorile distructive,
pe care le-am menționat în prezentarea generală a lecției. Un mod de a descrie o măsurătoare distructivă
este printr-o colecție de matrice, unde avem în particular o matrice pentru fiecare rezultat posibil al măsurătorii.
Al doilea mod de a descrie o măsurătoare distructivă este printr-un canal, unde
intrarea este starea oricărui sistem care este măsurat și ieșirea este întotdeauna o matrice densitate diagonală, pe care o putem
interpreta ca o descriere a unei distribuții de probabilitate peste posibilele rezultate clasice ale măsurătorii.
Cele două descrieri sunt echivalente și asta e destul de util, deoarece ne permite să alegem oricare descriere este mai convenabilă într-o
situație dată. Vom vorbi și despre măsurătorile nedistructive, unde pe lângă un rezultat clasic al măsurătorii
este specificată și starea cuantică post-măsurătoare a sistemului care a fost măsurat.
Măsurătorile nedistructive sunt importante și apar frecvent, dar există un sens în care ele sunt
oarecum mai puțin fundamentale decât măsurătorile distructive din punct de vedere matematic. În particular, după cum se dovedește,
măsurătorile nedistructive pot fi întotdeauna descrise ca compuneri de canale și măsurători distructive, și
vom vedea cum funcționează asta un pic mai târziu în lecție. Acum, să aruncăm o privire la cum măsurătorile, adică măsurătorile distructive,
pot fi descrise ca colecții de matrice. Pe parcursul acestei discuții, vom presupune că X este un sistem care
este măsurat și, pur din motive de simplitate, vom face câteva ipoteze. Mai întâi vom presupune că
mulțimea stărilor clasice ale lui X constă din numerele întregi de la 0 la n minus unu, pentru un anumit număr întreg pozitiv n, și posibilele
rezultate ale măsurătorii sunt numerele întregi de la 0 la M minus unu, din nou pentru un anumit număr întreg pozitiv M. Nu există
nicio relație necesară între numerele n și M, ambele sunt numere întregi pozitive arbitrare și, bineînțeles, am putea înlocui
aceste mulțimi cu mulțimi arbitrare de stări clasice dacă am dori. Mai întâi, să reamintim cum funcționează măsurătorile proiective,
despre care am vorbit prima dată în a treia lecție a seriei. Dată fiind ipoteza că
rezultatele măsurătorii sunt numerele întregi de la 0 la n minus unu, descriem o măsurătoare proiectivă printr-o colecție
de proiecții Pi 0 până la Pi M minus unu, care sumează la matricea identitate, și aceste matrice au toate linii și
coloane corespunzătoare stărilor clasice ale lui X, sau altfel spus, toate sunt matrice n pe n.
Dacă x se află într-o stare cuantică descrisă de un vector de stare cuantică s, atunci fiecare rezultat posibil al măsurătorii
a apare cu probabilitate egală cu norma euclidiană la pătrat a lui Pi a înmulțit
cu vectorul s. Norma euclidiană la pătrat a oricărui vector este egală cu produsul interior al acelui
vector cu el însuși, deci obținem expresia afișată pe ecran și o putem simplifica un
pic folosind faptul că Pi a este o proiecție, deci înmulțirea ei cu ea însăși nu
face nimic, și în final putem rescrie expresia obținută într-un mod ușor diferit folosind proprietatea ciclică
WEBVTT
a urmei, tot așa cum se arată pe ecran, și dacă nu e clar de ce am vrea să scriem expresia astfel,
răspunsul scurt este că am dori să înțelegem cum funcționează măsurătorile proiective pentru matricele
densitate și, în particular, prin liniaritate, avem că dacă starea lui X este descrisă de o matrice densitate rho, mai degrabă
decât de un vector de stare cuantică s, atunci probabilitatea ca rezultatul a să apară este dată de urma proiecției
Pi a înmulțită cu matricea densitate rho. Asta trebuie să fie cazul deoarece, după cum am văzut,
putem întotdeauna să gândim o matrice densitate ca o medie ponderată de stări pure și dacă facem media
probabilităților corespunzătoare, obținem această expresie deoarece urma este o funcție liniară, deci asta este expresia pe care o urmărim
și putem simplifica lucrurile un pic pentru a ne concentra pe matricele
densitate. Scopul principal al acestui demers, apropo, este de a stabili un punct de referință față de ceea ce am învățat deja
și de a vedea că această descriere a măsurătorilor proiective este de fapt un caz special al unei descrieri mai generale a măsurătorilor pe care
urmează să o vedem. Deci, ceea ce voi face acum este să înlocuiesc această descriere a modului în care funcționează măsurătorile proiective pentru matricele densitate
cu descrierea pentru măsurătorile generale, astfel încât să putem înțelege relația, și iată
ce avem. O măsurătoare generală, nu neapărat o măsurătoare proiectivă, este descrisă de o colecție de matrice pozitiv semidefinite
p 0 până la PM minus unu, care sumează la identitate, și dacă această măsurătoare este efectuată pe X cât timp se află
într-o stare descrisă de o matrice densitate rho, atunci fiecare rezultat a apare cu probabilitate egală cu urma lui PA înmulțit cu
rho. Pe scurt, singurul lucru care s-a schimbat este că am relaxat condiția pentru aceste matrice. În particular, matricele
nu trebuie să fie matrice de proiecție, ci trebuie doar să fie pozitiv semidefinite și, corespunzător, am înlocuit litera Pi cu litera p,
deoarece Pi este un nume convențional pentru o proiecție, pe când prefer să folosesc litera P pentru matricele pozitiv semidefinite.
Aceasta este o generalizare a descrierii pe care o aveam pentru măsurătorile proiective, apropo, deoarece matricele de proiecție sunt întotdeauna pozitiv
semidefinite și, de fapt, pot fi definite alternativ ca matrice pozitiv semidefinite ale căror valori proprii
pot fi doar zero și unu. Putem observa că această definiție
are sens, în sensul că obținem întotdeauna un vector de probabilitate pentru probabilitățile rezultatelor, în modul următor:
în primul rând, aceste numere la care mă refer ca probabilități ale rezultatelor sunt întotdeauna numere reale nenegative, deoarece
atât PA cât și rho sunt pozitiv semidefinite, iar urma produsului a două matrice pozitiv semidefinite
este întotdeauna un număr real nenegativ, și vă las să vă gândiți de ce este
astfel. Și în al doilea rând, numerele trebuie să sumeze la unu, deoarece urma este liniară,
matricele p 0 până la PN minus 1 trebuie să sumeze la identitate, iar matricele densitate au urma egală cu
unu, deci indiferent de matricea densitate rho cu care am pornit, probabilitățile rezultatelor vor forma întotdeauna un
vector de probabilitate. Acum, să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple. Am menționat deja că
măsurătorile proiective sunt un caz special al măsurătorilor generale, deoarece proiecțiile sunt întotdeauna pozitiv semidefinite,
dar e frumos să începem simplu, deci să începem cu o măsurătoare în baza standard a unui qubit. Putem reprezenta o măsurătoare în baza standard
a unui qubit prin două matrice p 0 și P1, definite așa cum se arată pe ecran. p 0 este ket zero bra zero, iar P1 este ket unu
bra unu. Acestea sunt ambele matrice pozitiv semidefinite și sunt de fapt proiecții și se adunează clar la
identitate, deci împreună descriu o măsurătoare. Dacă aplicăm această măsurătoare unui qubit
aflat într-o stare descrisă de o matrice densitate rho, atunci probabilitatea ca rezultatul zero să apară este urma lui p 0 înmulțit cu rho
și probabilitatea pentru rezultatul unu este urma lui P1 înmulțit cu rho, și prin proprietatea ciclică a urmei, obținem
cele două intrări diagonale ale lui rho, așa cum ne așteptăm. Iată un alt exemplu unde de data aceasta
matricele nu sunt proiecții. Sunt însă pozitiv semidefinite și se întâmplă să fie și matrice
densitate, dar asta nu e important. Ceea ce este important este că sumează la identitate, deci împreună descriu o
măsurătoare. Putem vedea ce se întâmplă când această măsurătoare este efectuată pe un qubit în starea plus, de exemplu, pur și simplu pentru a
vedea cum funcționează pentru un exemplu de stare, iar calculul probabilităților este arătat pe
ecran. Observați în special că, deși starea plus este o stare pură și putem reprezenta acea stare prin vectorul de stare cuantică ket plus, trebuie totuși
să introducem reprezentarea matricei densitate a acelei stări, care este ket plus bra plus, în formule pentru a obține
probabilitățile. Și să mai remarc că, deoarece vorbim despre o măsurătoare distructivă, nu există nicio
specificare a stării cuantice post-măsurătoare a acestui qubit, deci tot ce avem este o specificare a probabilităților rezultatelor.
Iată un exemplu final pentru moment și este unul destul de interesant. Din nou, este o măsurătoare a unui
singur qubit și, pentru a-l descrie, vom începe prin a defini patru vectori de stare cuantică cunoscuți ca stările
tetraedrale. Motivul pentru care sunt numite stări tetraedrale este că ele corespund celor patru vârfuri ale
unui tetraedru regulat înscris în sfera Bloch. Și pentru a fi clari, când spunem că acesta este un tetraedru regulat,
ne referim la un solid cu patru fețe unde fiecare față este un triunghi echilateral, deci există o simetrie perfectă, fiecare
muchie are aceeași lungime și se formează același unghi între oricare două muchii adiacente.
Acum putem defini o măsurătoare interesantă cu patru rezultate posibile, așa cum se arată pe ecran. Sau în cuvinte, putem lua
matricele noastre să fie reprezentările matricei densitate ale acestor stări împărțite la doi. Acestea sunt cu siguranță matrice pozitiv
semidefinite, deoarece sunt matrice densitate împărțite la doi, și ai putea parcurge aritmetica pentru a verifica
că se adună de fapt la identitate. Dar un alt mod de a vedea asta este să te gândești la simetrie: dacă facem media acestor patru stări
împreună, obținem starea complet mixtă, care se află la centrul sferei Bloch, dar deoarece
împărțim fiecare la doi în loc de patru, obținem de două ori starea complet mixtă, care este identitatea. Nu voi mai spune nimic despre
această măsurătoare pentru moment, cu excepția observației că nu este o măsurătoare proiectivă, dar este un exemplu frumos și
o vom vedea din nou mai târziu în lecție. Un alt mod de a descrie măsurătorile generale este ca și canale, după cum vom
discuta acum. Ideea este că stările probabilistice clasice pot fi reprezentate prin matrice densitate diagonale și deci,
deoarece rezultatele măsurătorilor sunt clasice, putem gândi măsurătorile ca și canale unde ieșirea este întotdeauna o matrice densitate diagonală
WEBVTT
care descrie rezultatul măsurătorii. Deci, să aruncăm o privire mai detaliată la asta. Dacă gândim
abstract o măsurătoare generală, putem descrie acea măsurătoare ca un canal fi. Sistemul de intrare al canalului este
orice sistem X care este măsurat, iar sistemul de ieșire este un sistem y ale cărui stări clasice corespund
rezultatelor măsurătorii, pe care le considerăm a fi numerele întregi de la 0 la n minus unu, pentru un anumit număr întreg pozitiv
M. Și deoarece rezultatele măsurătorilor sunt clasice, cerem ca pentru orice matrice densitate de intrare rho pentru sistemul
X, ieșirea fi rho să fie o matrice densitate diagonală. De exemplu, dacă ne gândim la o
măsurătoare în baza standard a unui qubit și ne gândim la acea măsurătoare ca fiind descrisă de un canal, o putem exprima cum avem aici pe ecran.
Dacă matricea densitate de intrare este rho, atunci vom obține rezultatul zero cu probabilitate egală cu bra zero rho ket zero
și vom obține rezultatul unu cu probabilitate bra unu rho ket unu, și deci dacă exprimăm aceste
rezultate clasice ale măsurătorii ca matrice densitate, vom obține această expresie pentru canalul corespunzător și se dovedește
că nu este altceva decât canalul de defazare completă, și asta este consistent cu ideea că canalul de defazare completă
reprezintă o formă extremă de decoerență, care poate însemna lucruri diferite, dar când folosesc acest termen mă refer
la tendința stărilor cuantice de a deveni clasice deoarece mediul din jurul oricărui sistem despre care
vorbim observă cumva, sau altfel spus, măsoară.
Deci, rezultatele măsurătorilor pot fi descrise ca și canale, după cum tocmai am descris, dar aceasta nu este doar o posibilitate, ci o
caracterizare a măsurătorilor generale, și ce vreau să spun prin asta este următorul lucru. Bineînțeles că există canale
care nu reprezintă măsurători, deoarece ieșirea s-ar putea să nu fie întotdeauna o matrice densitate diagonală, dar dacă este
cazul că ieșirea unui canal este întotdeauna o matrice densitate diagonală, indiferent de ce stare de intrare rho alegem, atunci este în mod necesar posibil să
exprimăm acel canal în forma arătată pe ecran, pentru o anumită alegere a unei măsurători, adică o colecție de
matrice pozitiv semidefinite care sumează la identitate, și asta este bine din mai multe motive, inclusiv faptul că
ne spune practic că definiția noastră a măsurătorilor ca colecții de matrice nu lipsește
nimic. Un alt mod de a spune asta este că această modalitate de a gândi măsurătorile ca și canale este operațională
sau poate axiomatică, în sensul că surprinde ce ar trebui să fie o măsurătoare, care este un proces fizic ce
transformă informația cuantică în informație clasică, și se dovedește că este complet echivalentă cu prima noastră
descriere a măsurătorilor, care este pur algebrică. Nu voi parcurge demonstrația echivalenței în acest videoclip, dar
nu este dificilă și dacă ești interesat, poți găsi demonstrația în materialul scris al lecției, care este legat în descrierea videoclipului.
Am discutat ce se întâmplă când o măsurătoare generală este efectuată pe un sistem aflat într-o stare dată,
cel puțin pentru cazul măsurătorilor distructive. Urmează să vorbim despre măsurătorile parțiale, adică că doar
o parte a unui sistem compus este măsurată. Ca să fim preciși, să presupunem că avem o pereche de sisteme XZ care
împreună se află într-o stare descrisă de o matrice densitate rho, și o măsurătoare descrisă de o colecție de matrice pozitiv semidefinite care sumează la
identitate este efectuată pe sistemul X singur. Firesc, asta rezultă în
un rezultat al măsurătorii și, deoarece vorbim despre măsurători distructive, ne putem imagina că procesul de măsurare distruge sistemul
X, dar mai avem sistemul Z de care trebuie să ne preocupăm și trebuie să înțelegem cum măsurarea lui X afectează
starea lui Z. Mai întâi, să vorbim despre probabilitățile rezultatelor.
Deoarece vorbim despre o măsurătoare a sistemului X singur, probabilitățile pentru diferitele
rezultate care apar pot depinde doar de starea lui X în izolare, adică pot depinde doar de
starea redusă a lui X. În particular, probabilitatea ca un rezultat dat a să apară este dată de
aceeași formulă de mai înainte, care este urma lui PA înmulțit cu starea redusă a lui X, pe care o notăm cu rho
subx. Starea rho subx este obținută din rho prin urmărirea lui Z, deci putem face acea
substituție și, deși s-ar putea să nu fie imediat evident, întrebarea pe care o obținem poate fi scrisă alternativ cum se
arată pe ecran. Este urma lui PA tensoriat cu matricea identitate pe sistemul Z înmulțit cu
rho. Acum, aceasta este o egalitate care merită cu siguranță să fie verificată. Este intuitivă: nu facem
nimic deloc lui Z, deci are sens ca identitatea pe Z să apară în acest mod, dar poate fi verificată
și algebric, și vă las asta vouă, cu sugestia să considerați mai întâi cazul în care rho este un produs tensorial de două matrice și apoi
să folosiți liniaritatea pentru a concluziona că trebuie să funcționeze pentru orice rho. Și voi mai spune că nu depinde de faptul că PA
este pozitiv semidefinit sau că rho este o matrice densitate. Aceasta este o egalitate care ar funcționa pentru orice alegere de
matrice în locul lui PA și rho, atâta timp cât au dimensiunile corecte pentru ca expresia să aibă
sens. Acum, să vedem cum este afectată starea lui Z de măsurătoare, iar abordarea naturală din
punctul meu de vedere este să gândim măsurătoarea ca un canal. Iată canalul pe care îl asociem cu măsurătoarea noastră și
gândim asta ca un canal de la sistemul X la un nou sistem y ale cărui stări clasice corespund rezultatelor măsurătorii. Deci în această formulă,
Sigma reprezintă o stare a sistemului X singur. Dacă aplicăm acest canal pe
sistemul X în timp ce perechea XZ se află în starea rho, vom obține matricea densitate pe care o avem chiar aici.
Din nou, acordați-vă tot timpul necesar pentru a verifica asta, și din nou sugestia mea este să considerați mai întâi cazul în care rho este un produs
tensorial de două matrice și apoi să folosiți liniaritatea. Acum am văzut acest tip de stare
unde primul sistem este clasic și al doilea sistem este cuantic, ca exemplu în lecția despre matricele
densitate. Fiecare a apare cu o anumită probabilitate și aceea este urma celui de-al doilea factor tensorial, deci te poți gândi
la acești al doilea factori tensoriali ca matrice densitate înmulțite cu probabilități. Deci, pentru a obține starea
lui Z condiționată de obținerea unui anumit rezultat al măsurătorii a, pur și simplu împărțim probabilitatea sau, altfel spus,
normalizăm cel de-al doilea factor tensorial împărțindu-l la propria sa urmă. Deci, în rezumat, dacă efectuăm o
măsurătoare pe X în timp ce perechea XZ se află în starea rho, iată ce se întâmplă: mai întâi, fiecare rezultat a apare
cu probabilitate egală cu urma lui PA tensoriat cu identitatea înmulțit cu rho, și în al doilea rând, condiționat de obținerea
WEBVTT
unui anumit rezultat al măsurătorii a, starea lui Z este dată de expresia arătată pe ecran, care este ceea ce obținem
prin normalizarea matricei pe care tocmai am văzut-o cu un moment în urmă, și asta este același lucru cu împărțirea matricei la probabilitatea
pentru a apărea. Trebuie să menționez că asta are sens doar dacă probabilitatea este nenulă, deoarece altfel împărțim
la zero, dar nu-i nimic, deoarece nu trebuie să ne preocupăm de lucruri care nu se întâmplă. În această parte a
lecției, vom discuta o teoremă simplă dar fundamentală despre măsurători, cunoscută ca teorema lui Neymark.
Pe scurt, ceea ce spune este că orice măsurătoare poate fi implementată așa cum sugerează figura de pe ecran.
Exprimând asta în cuvinte, o măsurătoare generală dată pe un sistem X poate fi implementată în modul următor:
mai întâi introducem un sistem workspace inițializat y ale cărui stări clasice sunt posibilele rezultate ale măsurătorii, pe care presupunem că sunt
numerotate de la 0 la n minus unu. Apoi se efectuează o operație unitară U pe perechea
YX, după care se efectuează o măsurătoare în baza standard pe y. Deci totul este practic fixat
cu excepția alegerii lui U, și ceea ce spune teorema este că este de fapt posibil să alegem această operație unitară
U astfel încât probabilitățile pentru diferitele rezultate să concorde întotdeauna cu măsurătoarea generală dată.
Acum, să vedem cum se demonstrează teorema lui Neymark, și nu este dificil. Trebuie doar să facem o alegere bună pentru
operația unitară U și să verificăm că funcționează. Dar mai întâi avem nevoie de un fapt de bază
din teoria matricelor, și anume că pentru orice matrice pozitiv semidefinită P, există întotdeauna o unică matrice pozitiv semidefinită
Q astfel încât Q la pătrat este egal cu P. În general ar putea fi mai multe matrice care ridicate la pătrat să ne dea P, dar
există întotdeauna doar una dintre ele care este pozitiv semidefinită. Notația pe care o folosim pentru a denota această matrice este rădăcina pătrată a lui
P, și tot așa o numim în cuvinte. Dacă vrei să calculezi rădăcina pătrată a lui P pentru o anumită matrice pozitiv
semidefinită P, apropo, poți face asta calculând mai întâi o descompunere spectrală a lui P și apoi
înlocuind fiecare dintre valorile proprii cu rădăcina sa pătrată și lăsând vectorii proprii neschimbați. Valorile proprii sunt toate nenegative,
deci asta are sens și este destul de ușor de văzut că matricea pe care o obținem este de fapt pozitiv semidefinită
și se ridică la pătrat dând P. Unicitatea este o altă problemă, nu este dificil de
demonstrat folosind câteva fapte de bază despre matrice, dar este cam tangențial față de lecție și vom lua acea parte
ca dată. Acum că avem acel concept la îndemână, este destul de ușor să specificăm o
operație unitară U care funcționează. Orice matrice unitară care se potrivește cu modelul arătat pe ecran va
funcționa. Primele n coloane, presupunând că X are n stări clasice ca mai înainte, sunt obținute prin stivuirea rădăcinilor pătrate ale
matricelor care descriu măsurătoarea una peste alta, iar coloanele rămase pot fi orice
dorim, nu contează, atâta timp cât întreaga matrice este unitară.
Și apropo, dacă observați o asemănare cu legătura dintre reprezentările Kraus și Stinespring ale canalelor, nu e o coincidență,
iar de fapt ceea ce avem aici este în esență un caz special al acelora, unde matricele noastre Kraus se întâmplă să fie toate pozitiv
semidefinite. Deci există două lucruri pe care trebuie să le verificăm. Primul este că această alegere a lui U funcționează de fapt, iar
al doilea este că este posibil să alegem coloanele nespecificate în mod că U să fie unitar. Deci, să începem cu primul
lucru. Iată starea cu care pornim: sistemul de jos Y este inițializat la starea zero, pe când sistemul de sus
pornește în starea rho, și apoi efectuăm U, ceea ce înseamnă că conjugăm cu
U. Putem scrie asta complet în termeni de matrice bloc, așa cum se arată pe ecran. Avem U la stânga, U dagger la
dreapta, și ket zero bra zero tensoriat cu rho în mijloc, care ia forma pe care o avem aici, unde avem rho în
colțul din stânga sus și zerouri peste tot în rest. Și dacă te gândești la acest produs un moment, este evident că
intrările nespecificate ale lui U nu contează deloc, deoarece sunt întotdeauna înmulțite cu intrările zero ale acestei
matrice din mijloc, iar dacă parcurgem înmulțirea, obținem această
matrice arătată chiar aici, descrisă ca matrice bloc. Sau alternativ, o putem exprima folosind notația directă
astfel. Aceea este de fapt forma mai convenabilă pentru noi, deci să ne concentrăm pe această
expresie și, de dragul convenienței, să dăm acestei matrice, care este o matrice densitate, numele
Sigma. Ultimul pas este măsurătoarea în baza standard pe y, deci să calculăm starea redusă în y și
asta e ușor dată expresia pe care o avem. Pur și simplu urmărim X, care corespunde celui de-al doilea factor
tensorial. Deci probabilitatea ca orice rezultat dat a să apară este intrarea diagonală corespunzătoare lui a. Putem scrie
asta astfel și este egal cu urma rădăcinii pătrate a lui PA înmulțit cu rho înmulțit cu rădăcina
pătrată a lui PA, și prin proprietatea ciclică a urmei, obținem urma lui PA înmulțit cu rho,
ceea ce speram să obținem. Deci, probabilitățile pentru diferitele rezultate care apar sunt corecte: concorda întotdeauna
cu măsurătoarea originală cu care am pornit. Al doilea lucru pe care trebuie să-l verificăm
este că este posibil să completăm coloanele nespecificate ale lui U în mod că
acesta să devină unitar. Asta rezultă din faptul că primele n coloane, care sunt cele formate de rădăcinile pătrate ale matricelor care descriu
măsurătoarea, sunt ortonormale, și asta poate fi verificat destul de direct. Detaliile relevante sunt aici
pe ecran, deci oprește videoclipul și ia câteva momente să te gândești la asta dacă dorești, dar după cum am sugerat înainte,
este de fapt un caz special al unui lucru pe care l-am întâlnit în lecția anterioară, și asta este
demonstrația. Până acum în lecție, ne-am concentrat atenția pe măsurătorile distructive, adică nu există nicio specificare a
stării cuantice post-măsurătoare a sistemului care a fost măsurat. Pentru o măsurătoare nedistructivă, pe de altă parte, există
nu doar un rezultat clasic al măsurătorii, ci și o stare cuantică post-măsurătoare a sistemului care a fost măsurat, și după cum
vom vedea, există o legătură naturală cu teorema lui Neymark. Există de fapt diferite moduri de a formula măsurătorile nedistructive
în termeni matematici, dar vom începe cu o formulare care vine direct din teorema lui Neymark.
Considerăm o măsurătoare generală, adică una distructivă, descrisă de o colecție de matrice pozitiv semidefinite
p 0 până la PN minus unu care sumează la identitate. Putem apoi transforma aceasta
WEBVTT
într-o măsurătoare nedistructivă pur și simplu considerând implementarea acestei măsurători pe care am discutat-o în contextul teoremei lui Neymark.
Introducem un nou sistem y, îl facem să interacționeze cu X printr-o operație unitară U și apoi efectuăm o măsurătoare în
baza standard pe y. Deci sistemul X este încă acolo și putem considera starea sa
și pe baza analizei prin care am trecut, putem determina că starea post-măsurătoare a lui X condiționată de
obținerea unui anumit rezultat al măsurătorii a este dată de o matrice densitate care arată
astfel. În cuvinte, conjugăm cu rădăcina pătrată a matricei de măsurătoare corespunzătoare și apoi
normalizăm. Un alt mod de a formula măsurătorile nedistructive, care este mai general, este în termeni de matrice Kraus
ale canalelor, și aceasta este definiția măsurătorilor pe care o veți găsi în renumitul manual al lui Nielsen și
Chuang, de exemplu. Să presupunem că m0 până la m m minus 1 sunt matrice pătrate care satisfac
ecuația arătată pe ecran, adică ne putem gândi la aceste matrice ca matrice Kraus care descriu un
canal. De fapt, aceste matrice descriu un canal, dar descriu și o măsurătoare nedistructivă.
Și modul în care funcționează când un sistem aflat într-o stare dată rho este măsurat este: mai întâi, probabilitățile rezultatelor sunt
date de ecuația arătată pe ecran. Fiecare rezultat apare cu probabilitate egală cu urma lui ma înmulțit cu
rho înmulțit cu ma dagger, și condiționat de apariția rezultatului a, starea sistemului măsurat
arată astfel. Măsurătorile nedistructive de acest tip pot fi implementate într-un mod
similar cu ceea ce am avut pentru teorema lui Neymark, și vă las să vă gândiți la asta dacă
doriți. Este posibil să generalizăm conceptul de măsurătoare nedistructivă chiar mai mult decât asta. De exemplu,
există un concept de instrument cuantic care este uneori destul de util, dar nu voi acoperi asta în acest
videoclip. În ultima parte a lecției, voi discuta pe scurt două sarcini asociate cu măsurătorile: discriminarea stărilor cuantice și tomografia stărilor cuantice.
Există destul de multe de spus despre ambele aceste concepte și vom zgâria cu adevărat doar
suprafața. Deci, să începem prin a clarifica la ce se referă acești termeni și cum diferă.
Primul este discriminarea stărilor cuantice. Ideea este că avem o colecție cunoscută de stări cuantice
ale unui sistem, împreună cu probabilități asociate acestor stări. Deci, ca să fim preciși, să presupunem
că rho 0 până la rho M minus 1 sunt matrice densitate reprezentând posibile stări cuantice ale unui sistem X, și p 0
până la PN minus unu sunt probabilitățile asociate acestor stări. Deci, dacă adunăm probabilitățile într-un singur
vector, obținem un vector de probabilitate. Un mod succint de a spune asta, apropo, este că avem un ansamblu de stări cuantice.
Și acum un mod abstract de a gândi la discriminarea stărilor cuantice ca sarcină sau ca problemă
este: mai întâi, un număr între zero și N minus unu este ales aleatoriu conform probabilităților. Sistemul X este apoi
pregătit în starea corespunzătoare numărului selectat aleatoriu, iar scopul este să determini prin
intermediul unei măsurători a lui X care număr a fost ales. Deci avem un număr finit de
alternative împreună cu o distribuție a priori, iar scopul este să determinăm care alternativă s-a întâmplat de fapt. Pentru unele alegeri de stări și
probabilități, asta poate fi ușor, iar pentru altele poate fi imposibil să faci asta fără vreo șansă de a face o eroare.
Și există diverse întrebări specifice pe care le-am putea pune, cum ar fi care este probabilitatea minimă de a face o eroare
și cum arată o măsurătoare care atinge această probabilitate minimă de eroare. Tomografia stărilor cuantice, pe de
altă parte, este diferită. Aici avem o stare cuantică necunoscută a unui sistem, deci nu există
de obicei nicio distribuție a priori sau informație despre posibilele alternative. De data aceasta, însă, nu este o singură copie a stării care este pusă
la dispoziție, ci mai degrabă sunt puse la dispoziție multe copii independente, adică, pentru un număr n posibil mare,
avem n sisteme identice X1 până la Xn, fiecare preparat independent în starea
rho, iar de data aceasta scopul este să găsim o aproximare a acestei stări cuantice necunoscute ca matrice densitate, prin măsurarea
sistemelor. Deci, în rezumat, în discriminarea stărilor cuantice avem o singură copie a
stării și încercăm să discriminăm între un număr finit de alternative cunoscute, iar în tomografia stărilor cuantice avem multe copii independente
ale unei stări cuantice necunoscute, iar scopul este să găsim o descriere a acelei stări sau cel puțin o aproximare decentă a
ei. Discriminarea stărilor cuantice este interesantă deoarece abstractizează un tip de situație care apare frecvent în
calcul și criptografie, de exemplu, unde una dintr-un număr finit de posibilități s-a întâmplat și noi sau altcineva încearcă
să afle care a fost prin măsurarea unui sistem cuantic. Cel mai simplu caz non-trivial este
cel în care există doar două alternative, adică m este egal cu doi, deci sarcina este să discriminezi între o pereche
de stări. Acest caz se dovedește a fi în esență o problemă complet rezolvată, presupunând că scopul este să minimizezi
șansa unei discriminări incorecte. Există o alegere optimă pentru o măsurătoare și se numește adesea
măsurătoarea Helstrom. Este o măsurătoare proiectivă de fapt, și poate fi descrisă
astfel: mai întâi considerăm diferența ponderată dintre cele două alternative, adică p 0 înmulțit cu rho 0 minus P1 înmulțit cu rho unu.
Deci înmulțim probabilitatea de a extrage fiecare dintre aceste două stări cu stările în sine și luăm
diferența. Aceea este o matrice hermitică deoarece este egală cu propriul său conjugat transpus, deci are o descompunere
spectrală și știm în particular că valorile proprii sunt toate numere reale. Deci, să presupunem că avem o
descompunere spectrală scrisă în forma arătată pe ecran. Ceea ce facem în continuare este să colectăm
valorile proprii în două mulțimi, unde toate valorile proprii pozitive sunt într-o mulțime și toate valorile proprii negative sunt în
cealaltă. Ca să fim preciși, să luăm S0 ca mulțimea tuturor indicilor k pentru care valoarea proprie corespunzătoare Lambda K este
nenegativă, și să fie S1 indicii rămași, care sunt cei corespunzători valorilor proprii negative.
Nu contează de fapt care mulțime conține indicii corespunzători oricăror valori proprii zero de aici; facem
o alegere arbitrară de a include în zero, dar nu ar face nicio diferență dacă unele sau toate ar fi incluse în S1. Tot ce contează cu adevărat este
că separăm valorile proprii pozitive de cele negative. Și în final definim două proiecții Pi
0 și Pi 1 așa cum se arată pe ecran. În cuvinte, Pi 0 este proiecția pe
WEBVTT
subspațiul generat de vectorii proprii corespunzători valorilor proprii nenegative, iar Pi 1 este proiecția pe spațiul
generat de vectorii proprii corespunzători valorilor proprii negative. Acestea sunt într-adevăr proiecții și
dacă le adunăm, obținem matricea identitate, deoarece vectorii proprii S 0 până la S N minus unu formează o
bază ortonormală. Dacă această măsurătoare este efectuată în situația de față, adică
starea măsurată este rho 0 cu probabilitate p 0 și rho unu cu probabilitate P1, atunci se dovedește că
probabilitatea unei identificări corecte are o formulă destul de simplă în termenii valorilor proprii Lambda 0 până la Lambda n minus
unu. Nu voi parcurge detaliile calculului în acest videoclip; poți consulta conținutul scris legat în descrierea videoclipului dacă ești
interesat, sau încearcă să te convingi singur că această formulă este într-adevăr corectă. Putem exprima și această
probabilitate folosind o normă de matrice numită în mod obișnuit norma urmei. Este o notație similară cu norma euclidiană pentru vectori,
cu excepția că avem un indice de unu pentru a indica că este norma urmei. Norma urmei este foarte importantă și este
întâlnită foarte frecvent în quantum computing, dar nu voi mai spune prea multe despre ea în această lecție. Un mod de a
o defini pentru matricele hermitice este că este suma valorilor absolute ale valorilor proprii, deci te poți gândi
că această a doua egalitate rezultă direct din acea definiție. Norma urmei poate fi și
definită în alte moduri care sunt mai generale și vom întâlni norma urmei din nou în lecția următoare. Acesta este de fapt
cel mai bun rezultat posibil: această măsurătoare este optimă, presupunând că scopul tău este să maximizezi șansa unui
răspuns corect. Acel fapt se numește uneori teorema Helstrom-Holevo și se mai numește uneori pur și simplu teorema lui
Helstrom. Deci nu poți bate această măsurătoare în termeni de probabilitate de corectitudine, și este bine deoarece
există o rețetă simplă pentru măsurătoarea în sine și o formulă exactă pentru probabilitatea de corectitudine în termenii normei
urmei. Norma urmei este adesea folosită ca modalitate de a măsura diferența observabilă între matricele densitate,
tocmai din acest motiv, și când oamenii se referă la distanța urmei între stări, se referă de obicei la
o jumătate din norma urmei a diferenței dintre cele două matrice densitate, care corespunde cazului în care p 0 și P1 sunt ambele 1/2, ceea ce
este un caz natural de considerat. Discriminarea stărilor cuantice pentru două stări este rezolvată optim de
măsurătoarea Helstrom, pentru care avem o rețetă simplă și o formulă simplă pentru probabilitatea de
corectitudine. Deci ce se întâmplă când vrem să discriminăm între trei sau mai multe stări? În acest caz nu avem o
formulă în general pentru o alegere optimă a unei măsurători sau o expresie simplă pentru probabilitatea maximă de
corectitudine. Este totuși posibil să găsim o bună aproximare a unei măsurători optime cu ajutorul unui calculator
și, în particular, asta poate fi făcut folosind o tehnică de optimizare cu adevărat fascinantă și puternică, cunoscuta ca programare semidefinită, dar nu este
ceva ce poți implementa în mod fezabil folosind un creion și o foaie de hârtie, de exemplu. Pe de altă parte, dacă cineva
îți dă o descriere a unei măsurători și susține că această măsurătoare este optimă pentru o sarcină de discriminare a stărilor cuantice, atunci este
de fapt foarte ușor să verifici sau să infirmi acea afirmație, și asta poate fi făcut folosind așa-numitele condiții Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax. Nu voi explica ce sunt în acest videoclip, dar sunt condiții simple și este destul de cool
că asta este posibil. Iată un exemplu care ne întoarce la stările tetraedrale
pe care le-am văzut mai devreme în lecție. Să presupunem că ni se dă una din aceste patru stări selectată la întâmplare cu
probabilitate un sfert pentru fiecare, și scopul nostru este să determinăm care stare ni s-a dat. Nu e surprinzător poate, dar
cea mai bună alegere pe care o poți face pentru o măsurătoare în acest scop este măsurătoarea tetraedrală. Nu poți face întotdeauna
ceva de genul acesta pentru o colecție arbitrară de stări pure, dar datorită simetriilor implicate, asta
funcționează și obținem de fapt o măsurătoare validă, iar prin condițiile Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax pe care le-am menționat
cu câteva momente în urmă, se dovedește a fi destul de simplu să demonstrezi că aceasta este într-adevăr o alegere optimă a unei
măsurători. Specific, ce se întâmplă aici este că măsurătoarea este întotdeauna corectă cu probabilitate 1/2, ceea ce nu este
rău deoarece există patru alternative, deci probabilitatea unui răspuns corect este de două ori mai bună decât ghicitul aleatoriu, și se
întâmplă să fie cel mai bun rezultat posibil pentru aceste stări. Acum voi mai spune câte ceva despre tomografia stărilor cuantice,
unde avem multe copii independente ale unei stări cuantice necunoscute și scopul este să găsim o aproximare a matricei densitate care descrie
acea stare. Există de fapt mai multe variante diferite ale acestei probleme care depind de ipotezele tale și, în
particular, de ce tipuri de măsurători permiți. De exemplu, am putea cere ca fiecare sistem să fie măsurat individual și
rezultatele să fie combinate cumva pentru a ajunge la o descriere a matricei densitate, sau am putea permite ca toate
sistemele să fie măsurate împreună ca un singur sistem compus, ceea ce este mult mai bine în teorie, dar este și mult mai
pretențios din punct de vedere tehnologic. Pe lângă alegerile pe care le faci pentru măsurători, există
și o considerație importantă, care este cum să reconstruiești o descriere a matricei densitate din orice date pe care le
obții din măsurători. Nu voi intra în detalii despre asta; scopul meu este pur și simplu să sugerez
că tomografia stărilor cuantice este mai degrabă un concept umbrelă cu multe variante diferite, decât
o singură procedură. A existat o mare cantitate de cercetare în această problemă, inclusiv câteva rezultate destul de
recente care leagă numărul de copii n de acuratețea aproximării care poate fi obținută, și continuă să fie un
domeniu de cercetare interesant și activ. Ca să terminăm lecția, să aruncăm o privire la tomografia stărilor cuantice
pentru qubiți și cum o putem face. Deci, să presupunem că rho este o matrice densitate reprezentând starea unui
singur qubit, și X1 până la Xn sunt qubiți care au fost toți preparați independent în starea rho, și pentru
scopul acestei discuții să presupunem că n este mare. Ce putem face este să împărțim
sistemele în trei grămezi aproximativ egale, și pentru prima grămadă vom efectua o măsurătoare în raport cu baza plus
minus. Pentru fiecare rezultat corespunzător lui plus, vom înregistra plus unu, și pentru fiecare
rezultat corespunzător lui minus, vom înregistra minus unu. Un mod mai succint de a descrie această măsurătoare
este că este o măsurătoare Pauli X, deoarece stările plus și minus sunt vectori proprii ai matricei Pauli X și
valorile proprii corespunzătoare sunt plus unu și minus unu, și de fapt acesta este și un mod mult mai comun de a o descrie.
WEBVTT
Într-adevăr, valoarea așteptată pentru scor este egală cu urma lui Sigma x înmulțit cu rho. Acum, nu aflăm neapărat care este
această valoare așteptată, dar dacă facem media scorurilor obținute de-a lungul multor și multor încercări, este destul de probabil să obținem o
aproximare decentă a acestei valori așteptate, prin legea numerelor mari, și există câteva limite statistice bine cunoscute pe care le putem aplica
dacă vrem să fim mai cantitativi în privința acelei afirmații. Facem ceva similar cu Sigma y pentru a doua treime a
sistemelor. Singurul lucru care se schimbă aici este că folosim stările plus i și minus i, care sunt vectori proprii ai lui Sigma
Y, și similar pentru Sigma Z, pentru care vectorii bazei standard sunt vectori
proprii. Și în final, putem folosi formula arătată pe ecran, care ne spune care ar trebui să fie coeficienții
dacă rho este scris ca o combinație liniară de matrice Pauli, și înlocuind aproximările noastre pentru acești coeficienți
și ajustându-i eventual un pic pentru a ne asigura că obținem o matrice pozitiv semidefinită, obținem o aproximare a lui
rho. Bineînțeles, există detalii în care nu am intrat, cum ar fi acuratețea aproximării și gradul de
încredere la care ne putem aștepta, dar sper că asta îți oferă o idee de bază despre un mod în care tomografia poate fi efectuată pe un
qubit. Este posibil și să faci tomografia qubitului folosind măsurătoarea tetraedrală, și de fapt asta se dovedește
a fi destul de simplu și elegant, cel puțin în termeni matematici. Ce putem face este să efectuăm doar
această singură măsurătoare pe toate copiile independente ale stării noastre cuantice necunoscute și, folosind
remarcabila formulă arătată chiar aici, putem veni cu o aproximare a stării noastre prin estimarea urmei lui PK înmulțit cu
rho pentru fiecare K, prin fracția de ori în care apare rezultatul de măsurătoare corespunzător. Din nou, asta funcționează doar datorită
simetriilor perfecte pe care le avem între aceste patru stări, și există de fapt câteva probleme fascinante nerezolvate care se referă la generalizările
acestei abordări la sisteme mai mari, și acesta este un loc bun pentru a termina lecția. Mulțumesc că ai urmărit și
sper că te vei alătura mie pentru lecția următoare, care este despre purificări și fidelitate. La revedere pentru acum.